what's up rejects its Greg Alda here
pointlessly yelling at the camera ha
I'm here with colliders out clatter TV
talk you might see them on the show and
I see them all over Collider it's Josh
Moe good I can't swear anymore
restricted no Josh McKoon uh no Morris
Larry no mortuary I'm trying it's a work
in progress man aren't real a little be
deleted takes to go on the patreon so
Josh cuckoo adult Selina has the josh
mokuba show on YouTube John and I were
guests on there gets crushed we had a
wonderful interview they're like ok I
guess we're going for these questions
today yeah we agreed to be honest though
the heavier element
I actually had a text on ok there's one
part I'm hoping you can cut happen if
you have no idea how often that happens
now you're such a good host until
relaxing ah thanks man
well hey Josh Joshua Kouga the man who
this is month in the making of making
sure we could collab yes there's this
trailer I'll call 222 okay I have no
idea
best title in the world mm-hmm it's
rated pg-13 I'm going to hit play okay
violence is some sexualities I like both
those yes I like a lot of sexuality
combined with five
because if you're yourselves over you
get something where away my story
Altamont he forgave not being bad some
everyday routines I'm gonna nearly
people for me to gain when ordering
became
do it you didn't hold him all right
punch it Oh Hilary LaVon that is P palms
what a love story it's a sapphic is a
bit of yeah with my sight
it was nearly killed nine hundred people
nah you saved me you like we've known
each other forever
with you third row
oh crap all day gonna sound ridiculous
all happen he's going to shame people
[Music]
the marzipan batter what's really going
he's happy why didn't I possibly be
funny
exactly - oh wow and everything it's all
complete [ __ ]
[Music]
your pattern don't mean haha I don't
know I think it ought to come we've all
gonna die Oh Godfrey need to end now
[Music]
interesting
I'm never gonna look at when did I
mention xxx I mean okay first of all
yeah looks like four different movies
and yeah like at the beginning I'm like
oh [ __ ] it could be like an airline does
that and then and then I'm like oh it's
age of Adaline like and then all of a
sudden it's butterfly fatness and then
it's like such a slow-motion bullets
like a glass breaker there's so many
different tones in here I don't think
they're going for cheesy it looks rather
cheesy yes although even if it they're
not intentionally going for cheesy I
could see myself enjoying this film no
for some reason there's a party and it's
like it looks kind of cool yeah kind of
head I'm so intrigued by Catholics it's
called 222 basically there's 222 story
lines in the movie and we have to figure
out how they all come together ah at 222
all 222 shows because I mean the whole
writing of the glass I mean it looks
like a little bit of die hard 2 in there
there's Airport I don't know what that
job is called at the airport I'm like
air traffic control there Wow
the brains on the Kouga there are they
like that scientifically heavy when he's
like doing all this stuff that you would
see in like the flash on it I mean W you
got imagine the good with numbers that's
the way I know what coordinates lights
all over the country all day long it
looks like he's at LAX or JFK one hand I
mean you would imagine it would have to
be pretty good at numbers but then again
let's I mean you watch Breaking Bad yeah
okay spoiler alert those planes collide
the air yeah I know I mean this sort of
looks like a little bit of Breaking Bad
I guess this is all over the place but
it's Dario and Teresa Palmer and I'd be
awesome yeah I mean it's cool to see him
in a movie I know you know it's fun I
just wish more actors you go from TV to
movies get like that role in a movie
where you're like this they're going to
be a movie star but this trailers not do
that forever yeah it has those elements
like you put on a butterfly
it has the groundhog day element we
finally elevation yeah yeah yeah it has
so many of these other sci-fi I think
this would have worked better if they
kind of went for a straight horror feel
I'm not sure what the feel is of this
it's like like abusing the driller
rom-com what kind of like a young adult
novel would it's not it's a throm
condoms wrong company we have made up a
new genre here the throne come this is
the kind of movie that my mom would like
to turn to be like I don't get it yes
because to be honest with you it is
quite confusing
well it's he looks like he's a hero in
the matter though yeah I mean I don't
get why she was falling for him in that
bar scene I guess we'll have to see that
scene save his life in the world come on
yeah my first thought though it was his
fault though why they were about to
collide so he had no choice but to see
you he couldn't kill 900 people really
when I ain't pretty betrayed okay yeah
that's simple to get a woman huh put
their life in danger killed on your go
kill them and you're their garage I tell
me my fiancee me
oh is this kind of move you take your
fiance to now she wouldn't go this
no no what kind of shades good next
fifty shades she goes with the lady
friend yeah those shades keep getting
darker gray before you know it and we
totally black dude alright well thanks
everyone who sent this trailer away I
definitely had fun watching that one if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Belka subscribe button
filming anything follow us on our
recently launched spate Road exclusive
video segment i want to ask Josh can we
do a interview with you the Sun sensor
yeah patreon will be luminous pump
source wait yes of course as always
follow josh mokuba at this is just Josh
mccoon Renault at their Zoe's just at me
and another Josh McKoon yeah I put the
old done from the mid what and there's a
bike to go mokuba is Italian we're doing
me I'm at half a cow and I know this I
know I'll go other and of course
Collider TV talk Hawaii unlike
everything else collateral do a lot of
Claudia's predator
thread the well and kept check on his
latest Rodale match find out if he wins
and aren't my throw down match with
double toast the whole week because that
we defeated them and they only gotten
one point that has a spoiler that is
sure okay yeah boy when his sword